- We're here in the streets of
New York asking people do they
like the New York Jets or not.
Let's see what happens.
(rap music)
("Vibes" by Jim Boonie)
I need three fire video a day
for Instagram.
Gonna try to do more to my
phone camera on the vlog
'cause DRock's pushing it.
God, these are awesome.
And DRock is boss.
- [DRock] Not true.
- Not true.
Very fuckin' meta.
Literally the worst moments of
my life is watching DailyVee.
Such a waste of time but
gotta make sure these guys don't
fuckin', I don't need Iris or
Justin slipping
something in by accident.
DRock, you're finally there.
Trust you somewhat.
I think so.
- Yeah.
- Third time's a charm.
Gonna bring it hard.
To make 10 million,
to make 50 million,
I'm trying to buy
the New York Jets.
- Everything you could've
said, you gonna buy the Jets?
- [Cha] He's been
saying that for years.
That's his motivation.
- [Envy] What about the Giants?
- Breakfast Club,
Power 105.1, should be good.
- [Man] Is this one of
your favorite interviews?
- Yeah. I love these guys.
- [Man] Yeah.
- It just feels like home.
- [Cha] GaryVee!
- [Gary] What up my man?
- What's up my brother?
- [Gary] Good to see ya.
- [Cha] How is
everything? DRock!
- [Angela] How are you?
- [Gary] Love the pink on pink.
- [Angela] Oh, this is
just for in here. I'm cold.
- Envy, how are you, man?
- [Envy] How is everything?
- Things are good.
How are you?
- [Envy] I'm great, man.
- How's your little man?
He's making money?
- [Envy] He's doing good.
Slime is still doing good.
- Slime is on fuckin' fire.
- [Envy] She wants to know how
to get that hustle died down.
- I see, got you Audrey.
Look, I mean look,
either you give a shit, oh.
- Go ahead.
- I forgot right, good, perfect.
Either you give a shit about
what other people
think or you don't.
The curveballs that are thrown
at life are either insular or
you care about
what other people think.
So if bad things are happening,
usually people break down 'cause
they're worried about
what their friend thinks,
what their mom thinks,
what their aunt thinks,
what the market thinks.
When bad things have happened
to me or when I see other people
that I've seen win,
when bad things happen,
they go inside themselves and
they just calibrate it
with themselves.
Audrey, listen, life's gonna
always throw you curveballs.
You know, you could
be on top of the world
and the next day it's over.
And so, I think it's
basically about how you think.
I guarantee the reason you are
even asking that question is you
care too much what
other people think.
("My Thang" by Kim)
Pictures with these guys.
DRock is here.
You guys need me in there?
- [Man 2] Yes sir.
- There you go,
here you go, here you go.
Currently what app do you
use the most frequently?
Probably Instagram.
You know, I just follow the
attention and at the end of the
day Instagram is
where people are at.
But, let me drop a
little knowledge here,
Snapchat's sneaky.
Like everybody's kinda saying
it's ghost and I'm getting more
than ever on there.
Truth is Snapchat,
Facebook, Twitter,
Instagram, YouTube, all of it.
Anything I could ever do.
- You did a much better
job at that promo than I did.
(Gary laughs) I'm gonna
get a little bit shamed here.
- That's okay. You do so
many things better than I do.
I want people to realize the
problem isn't the other person,
the problem is that
you're fucking trying to take.
- [Sam] Right. Right, yeah.
- Like when you judge,
why did you small talk me?
I'll tell you why I small talked
you because you're always coming
and asking for shit
without bringing any value.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- People have to
think about that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Gary] You know what I mean?
Like for me, you know
what I love everybody?
Do you honestly know
why I like everybody?
No, 'cause I don't fucking
need anything from anybody and
I don't expect
anything from anybody.
So, nobody disappoints me.
- [Sam] Right.
- I don't judge anybody.
Of course I want them to
win but more importantly
I don't want anything from them.
- [Sam] Right.
- That's the fuckin' key.
- [Sam] It's interesting.
One of the things that excites
me most about Vayner Talent is
helping musicians,
helping people that
have tons of influence--
- [Gary] Make a
far greater impact.
- and yeah, show the
behind the scenes side.
- [Gary] 100%.
- [Sam] I mean, they get
celebritized for the flashy stuff
when in reality the reason that
they've gotten to that stage is
'cause they do what's
happening behind the scenes.
- [Gary] It's why I do DailyVee.
- [Sam] Exactly, man.
- Like, I love my
episodes that are boring.
- [Sam] Right.
- Or the same shit.
- [Sam] Yeah.
- 'Cause that's
the fuckin' punch line.
- [Sam] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Gary] The thing that excites
me about DailyVee is not,
listen, there's two things.
There's many
things that excite me.
- [Sam] Right.
- It'd be so fun to
look back when I'm 59,
63, 72 be like "Oh,
I ran into Malcolm back then."
- [Sam] Right.
- You know, like this.
- Watching this will be fun.
- [Sam] For sure.
- But what's way more
fun is the body of work.
- [Sam] Yeah.
- When episode 5,000 basically
looks like episode 219,--
- [Sam] Right.
- that's when people
are gonna be like fuck.
- [Sam] Yeah.
It's the reps.
- [Gary] You know?
It's the reps, man.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Gary] It's the studio time.
- [Sam] Right.
- It's the snaps.
- [Sam] Yeah.
- It's the repetition.
- It's the meeting after meeting
after meeting after meeting.
- [Sam] Yeah.
- Pattern recognition,
refining, pattern recognition,
refining, pattern
recognition, refining.
Getting punched in the mouth,
swallowing that blood.
Finding your opening,
finding that breakthrough,
being right, being wrong.
- [Sam] Right.
- (imitating a gear
clicking over) The process.
- [Sam] Yeah.
- And nobody's really documented
the process at the scale that
I'm thinking
about accomplishing.
- [Sam] Right.
- Look what that guy's doing.
- [DRock] I know. That's crazy.
- [Gary] Get that.
- [DRock] I got it,
I got it. Nope.
- [Gary] Yeah! Let's go.
I got fired up.
("My Thang" by Kim)
Hey guys.
- [Man 3] How are you?
- [Gary] Morning, how are you?
Hey.
- [Man 4] I'm going
to high school right now.
- Is this going to
be your freshman year?
- [Man 4] Yeah.
- Are you shitting your pants?
- [Man 4] No.
("Block 4" by Kim)
I really thought that
was the scariest jump.
I thought the scariest jump
was junior high to high school.
That's more than any jump ever
that seemed like
the craziest one.
Yeah, like the older siblings
and I was the
first from an immigrant.
I was like, "What that fuck?"
Yeah. Alright, go ahead.
Alright, I'm gonna
figure out what I'm gonna do.
I'll be back.
I won't leave you guys hanging.
Going good in there?
- Yeah, man.
- Get over here,
we're gonna take a picture.
Going into a meeting at MTV.
See what happens.
We're here in the streets
of New York asking people
do they like the
New York Jets or not.
Let's see what happens.
I so don't want
to bother people.
It's so funny.
When you promote
an Instagram post,
is the visual to
the end consumer?
- [Andy] What do you mean?
- Do they see anything?
- [Andy] That it's promoted?
- Yeah.
- [Andy] Yes.
- But what about
people that see it organic?
- [Andy] No.
- So if DRock follows
me and we promote,--
- [Andy] If he saw
it as a promoted post.
- Correct. But not if he didn't.
- [Andy] Correct.
- Love it.
On a negative front the,
my push notifications
isn't working.
The 60 Second Club
is not working but
that's happened
once or twice before.
- Meaning they're not
getting notifications.
- Yeah.
- I get notifications.
The notifications are
always sort of delayed though.
- No, right now it like--
- Not at all.
("My Thang" by Kim)
- But you're right.
Google's entire
business is at stake.
Every single person in here
is gonna search through voice
before they die.
Every single person
that's eight years old
only searches through voice.
One in every five searches
on Google are voice,
according to Google.
According to Google who has
risk of losing their business to
report that number.
- [Tyler] HBO.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Tyler] There's a mix up.
- [Gary] Okay.
- [Tyler] 3 to 4.
- Okay.
What time is that?
- [Tyler] 3:20.
- [Gary] Okay.
- [Tyler] It's a 10 minute,
12 minute ride over there.
- [Gary] They'll take me.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Okay.
- You should go now.
- And come back.
- [Gary] I have to go to HBO.
There was a mix up,
I'll be right back.
I'll be back in like an hour.
Hey, I ran into your boyfriend.
Yeah, such a nice guy.
- [Man 5] So random, right?
- [Gary] So random.
What's that?
- I want to be in the vlog.
- [Gary] Fuckin' DRock.
- [Man 5] Send me the--
- [Gary] The raw footage?
We'll get it.
Like it'll be such
a winning thing to do.
You know?
- Hi.
- I came from
Australia to see you.
- How are you?
All the way from
Australia just for this?
- And I've walked
here from NoLIta.
- You better be
doing something else.
- My legs are killing me and
I was just about to leave.
- Timing is everything.
- Can I ask you something?
'Cause I can never get
through from Australia.
- Sure. Go ahead.
- Okay, very quickly
'cause I, hi DRock.
I'm a mental performance coach
and I'm stuck with content.
I don't know what the fuck I'm
supposed to do content-wise.
I can't show people the brain.
- Of course. I'll help you.
- Really?
- Yep.
I'll get you some intros.
- You're gonna
make me cry right now.
But I have come
here from Sydney, okay.
- Take a photo?
- Yeah.
- Here.
("My Thang" by Kim)
You know what I think I'm
trying to do to the market?
What my did for me at 14. Right?
I was on my way.
I would've been
the worst of the bunch.
I'd be the alpha worst.
I'd be the number one worst.
I'd probably be making $300,
$400 million a year right now.
Bad.
Like all from the worst and
the ones that could never.
And he saved me.
(spits in hand) Right?
So I'm impacting
you in that year, right?
- [Man 6] Yeah.
- And if you stay the course,
it'll get to a
really interesting place.
You know what the best
part is for guys like us?
- [Man 6] Stay the course.
- We still have
that ability to sell.
Once you deploy it against
something you truly believe all
the way, it just
compounds at a level that
becomes so much greater legacy.
("Block 4" by Kim)
You mean this?
Yeah, that's right.
I want you on the vlog.
You have to inspire
the next generation.
- Next generation?
Look at me, they don't
want to be inspired by me.
- I'm inspired by you.
You own an
AFC East football team.
That inspires me.
I want one too.
- Well that's only 'cause I'm
much better than your team.
(Gary laughs)
- My team's not gonna win a
single fuckin' game this year.
- Well, maybe one.
- May sneak one by you guys.
Exactly. Knocks you
out of the playoffs.
- As long as
they're not through me.
- How are you?
You're really
spinning a spinner.
That excites the shit.
You know what I love about you?
Do you make slime too?
Do you know about that trend?
Yeah, I love it.
("Block 4" by Kim)
What do you want to do, mister?
You really want a
Super Bowl, right?
- Of course.
There are a
number of things I want.
- [Gary] Well fuckin'
give me an answer.
You just said live.
Now you just said a lot.
Give me something.
- Want to win a Super Bowl.
- [Gary] Okay, what else?
You want to see me
buy the Jets, don't you?
That's important to you.
- [Stephen] Yeah,
I'd like to live that long.
- [Gary] Well listen,
20 years. Can you do it?
- 20 years?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- I don't think you
can do it in 20 years.
- [Gary] You've, you really
just pissed me the fuck off.
- [Stephen] Okay.
- Alright. What else?
I'm definitely
doing it in 19 now.
- [Stephen] 19, you're
gonna do it in 19 years
you'll buy the Jets.
- Yeah, yeah.
Alright, text me
the time you're there.
The whole weekend?
- Yeah, Friday
to Tuesday morning.
- Breaking news,
AJ's having a baby
so that's the end of this show.
- You're good?